мали труднощі зі збором
інформації, я не думаю, що пам’ятаю, щоб у
них були проблеми з отриманням інформації
на вежах мобільного зв’язку, до яких вони могли отримати доступ
, це було важко для
розслідування, тому сепаратисти
не спрощували це для офіційного
розслідування, тому я думаю, що
інформація є відкритою  дуже цінний для
цього розслідування, тому що
це щось, що не можна контролювати так само
легко, як вид доступу на землю. Я
маю на увазі, що це дуже зручно з цими
розслідуваннями, і це може бути
питанням десятиліть, так, особа, яка
цікавить, де  чи я все ще важко
запитав, тож нам все одно потрібно набратися
трохи терпіння, коли
будуть визначені особисті інтереси, але тим
часом ми тепер знаємо, що розвантажувальна
станція, який тип ракети
був, звідки її випустили, я
колишній  - Я сам військовий, ви знаєте, яка ваша
ціль, ви знаєте, куди ви замикаєтеся, у
вас також є фактичні дані літака
, тому людина повинна командувати
fi  re несе повну відповідальність